nichts ist gut in der Ukraine aber macht
der Westen eigentlich noch genug Druck
auf Russland oder stellt sich
mittlerweile eine kriegsmöglichkeit ein
die Grünen topminister in Sorge
was wenn der vielbeschworenen
Solidarität mit der auch unsere Freiheit
verteidigenden Ukraine die Luft ausgeht
[Musik]
weil die immer gleichen Bilder sich
abnutzen
weil uns die Empathie verlässt für die
Jüngsten Einzelschicksale in den
Nachrichten
garantieren müssen dass wir nicht
kriegsmüde werden dass die
Gesellschaften in Europa nicht einfach
zu anderen Themen übergehen
wie lange werden wir ohne Murren der
Preisspirale zusehen für das gute Gefühl
das Richtige zu tun
und wann denken wir wieso nicht wie die
Ungarn Tschechen Slowaken
es fängt schon wieder an
zu bröseln und zu bröckeln und tut das
jetzt beschlossene
eu-öl-putin überhaupt weh
er kann das Öl leicht Abfüllen in Tanka
es gibt da genug Kapazitäten das Öl
embargo ist ja auch nicht komplett das
wird ihm nicht besonders schaden
und wir begrüßen den Vizekanzler Robert
Habeck Herr Habeck großer Aufwand wenig
Effekt und am Ende bleibt es
festzuhalten dass Europa sich wieder
nicht einig ist ist das das Ergebnis
nicht ganz es ist natürlich richtig was
der Füßen gesagt hat Öl das über Schiff
transportiert werden kann kann woanders
hin transportiert werden deswegen wäre
ein Öl im Baro dass die Pipelines mit
eingeschlossen hätte der konsequente und
richtige Schritt gewesen das kriegt man
eben nicht so leicht weg das ist jetzt
aus den bekannten Gründen nicht zustande
gekommen gleichwohl machen wir einen
Fehler wenn wir immer nur über die
Rohstoffe uns definieren und auf das Öl
oder das Gas schauen die Sanktionen die
der Westen verhängt hat sind höchst
wirksam die russische Wirtschaft ist
tief getroffen die Investitionen sind um
30 über 30 Prozent zurückgegangen das
BIP ist eingebrochen die
Wirtschaftskraft ist eingebrochen und
vor allem die Exporte nach Russland also
das was Russland importiert das ist um
über die Hälfte zurückgegangen auch die
deutsche Wirtschaft hat massiv
zurückgeschraubt das heißt Putin hat
zwar Geld das stimmt aber er kann sich
immer weniger davon kaufen und es ist
immer weniger davon kaufen das wird sich
dann in den Prozessen an den Flughäfen
bald sehr schnell bemerkbar machen also
die Sanktionen selbst sind schon
höchstwirksam dann schließe ich damit an
dass Wladimir Putin 25% der Ukraine
mittlerweile besetzt mit seiner Armee
wenigstens sagt dass der ukrainische
Präsident heute sie haben gesagt Herr
Habeck die Bundesregierung hatte
beschlossen nicht über Waffenlieferungen
zu sprechen war das im Nachhinein ein
Fehler weil man einfach an der
Glaubwürdigkeit Deutschlands gezweifelt
hat und an dem Willen der Ukraine
wirklich zu helfen na es hat jedenfalls
die Kommunikation nicht leichter gemacht
das hat der Bundeskanzler gestern
besprochen und er war der Einzige der es
durchbrechen konnte
ganz genau und dann hat man jetzt
gesehen dass es erstens viel ist und
zwar ein sehr moderner Waffen dabei sind
die Panzer bitte
kann wirklich was die Ukraine kriegt
eins der modernsten Flugabwehrsysteme
also das ist jetzt nicht nur
ausgedienter Schrott den wir dahin
schicken ganz im Gegenteil auch die
panzerfeuchte Waren im übrigen oder die
stringerabwehrraketen waren hoch höchst
moderne Waffen aber natürlich weil die
Kommunikation etwas erschwert es hat
allerdings einen guten Grund es sind
eben Waffen und potenzielle
Angriffsziele und wenn man ankündigt
morgen fahren ein paar LKWs rüber dann
darf man sich nicht wundern wenn die
dann nicht mehr rüberfahren also
insofern war das richtig aber natürlich
auch hat es uns die Kommunikation nicht
leichter gemacht es ist doch aber mit
der Zweifel im Raum dass diese Waffen
überhaupt auf den Weg geschickt werden
sollten wir haben einen Gast heute in
unserer Sendung der sagt es steht zu
befürchten dass der Bundeskanzler nicht
will dass die Ukraine siegt warum sagt
Olaf Scholz nicht dass die Ukraine
diesen Krieg gewinnen muss es ist mir
ein bisschen aufpassen dass wir Politik
mit Bekenntnis verwechseln was heißt
denn Siegen wenn Sie mir kurz die defin
von Sieg geben dann können wir darüber
uns mal unterhalten könnte zum Beispiel
sagen dass auf jeden Fall das erreicht
werden sollte und wieder zurückgewonnen
wer werden bei Status Quo am 24.2 des
Jahres 22 war wenn man das als Sieg
definiert seitens des Bundeskanzlers
wäre das ein klares Ziel wenn das das
Ziel der Ukraine ist dann ist es das
Kriegsziel was ein bisschen schwierig
ist ist dass Deutschland der Westen die
Medien wir Politiker schon wieder in der
Ukraine sagen was sie wollen soll das
haben wir ja lange genug getan sie aber
nicht dabei unterstützt jetzt haben wir
den Spieß mal umgedreht und gesagt wir
unterstützen die Ukraine bei ihren
Kriegszielen und und das es klingt wie
das gleiche ist aber ein feiner
Unterschied wenn die Ukraine definiert
was ein erfolgreicher Abschluss des
Krieges ist dann ist das die viel
weitergehende Aussage als
als einen müssen dass wir der Ukraine
jetzt wieder vorgeben wir werden darüber
heute hier in dieser Sendung auch
diskutieren glauben Sie wirklich dass
das so ist dass am Ende nicht auch
Washington und am Ende natürlich auch
London und am Ende nicht auch Paris
mitbestimmen wie ein möglicher Frieden
aussehen kann
nur wenn sie der Ukraine die
Unterstützung bei ihren Kriegszielen
verweigern und das wiederum kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen ich glaube es wird eine
komplizierte Debatte wenn wir mit einer
unklaren Situation konfrontiert werden
deswegen wäre es jetzt wirklich
hilfreich wenn sich die unterstützenden
Länder der Ukraine Europa die USA die
transatlantische bündnisgemeinschaft
darauf verständigen dass die Ukraine
darüber bestimmt wie der Krieg
erfolgreich abgeschlossen werden kann
und erfolgreich abgeschlossen heißt eben
dass sie nicht verlieren Sieg wiederum
ist ein nach oben offener Begriff und
jetzt will man nicht rum spekulieren was
das alles heißen kann aber die die
Möglichkeiten diesen Krieg erfolgreich
abzuschließen sind ja vielfältig und sie
schließen eben auch natürlich mit ein
und das kann man ja eigentlich nur
hoffen dass es irgendwann eine
diplomatische Chance gibt das allerdings
kann nur die Ukraine entscheiden ob sie
ob sie genutzt wird bzw wie sie
hergestellt wird und sicherlich kann sie
erst dann entstehen wenn put nicht mehr
militärisch gewinnen kann nach wie vor
bittet die Ukraine bittet selensky um
schwere Waffen es gab einen
Bundestagsbeschluss Ende April wo das
Parlament beschloss Marder und Leopard
Panzer zügig zu liefern auch das ist
bisher noch nicht geschehen noch mal die
Frage an Sie Ringtausch Marder nach
Griechenland dafür diese bmp1 darüber
werden wir hier auch diskutieren noch
mal die Frage an sie glauben Sie dass
diese Bundesregierung alles mögliche tut
um die Ukraine zu unterstützen damit sie
in diesem Sinne siegreich aus diesem
Krieg kommt nein wir tun nicht alles
mögliche das ist ja die ehrliche Antwort
die wir Anfang gegeben haben wir wollen
nicht und dürfen nicht Kriegspartei
werden gar nicht nur aus Angst vor den
Leben unser eigenen Soldaten die dann
auf dem Schlachtfeld sterben würden
sondern weil wir damit dann den Schritt
zu einem globalen Krieg gehen würden
deswegen ja es ist richtig wir tun nicht
alles was wir können aber wir tun alles
was
dankbar ist der Ukraine jetzt in dieser
Situation zu helfen um es einmal
durchzugehen wir haben aus Dänemark
kommend über Deutschland knapp 60
gepanzerte große Fahrzeuge geliefert die
gleichen die die Amerikaner geliefert
haben wir haben die Marder verabredet
mit Tschechien Polen und Griechenland
auszutauschen gegen Panzer sowjetischer
Bauart der Ringtausch ist also dann
abgeschlossen die 100 Marder die es
ungefähr gab sind dann in den anderen
Ländern kannst du auch bis zu 2000 das
ist wirklich hochmoderne Artillerie habe
ich schon genannt das Flugabwehrsystem
habe ich genannt weitere Geräte sind
auch dazu das sind schwere Waffen das
ist aber alles noch nicht angekommen in
der Ukraine ich frage noch mal
andersherum das ist nicht richtig die
Fahrzeuge sind unterwegs und natürlich
sind die Geräte die wir am Anfang des
Krieges versprochen haben nicht nur
nicht angekommen sondern die sind
wahrscheinlich schon verschossen richtig
und ich rede trotzdem vor Kiew mit
gestoppt haben den
vormarschiert mit gestoppt und trotzdem
noch mal die Frage warum hat man das
Gefühl dass Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
ein unsicherer Kantonist ist wenn
europäische Zeitungen wenn
US-amerikanische Zeitungen so etwas
schreiben wenn osteuropäische
Regierungschefs das sagen ist das dann
nur eine Kampagne
ich bin jetzt hier nicht der
Medienkritiker aber Olaf Scholz die
Bundesregierung ist völlig klar in der
Linie und dass wir manchmal zweimal
drüber nachdenken und unsere Meinung
austauschen widerspricht dem überhaupt
nicht es ist doch gut wenn am Kabinett
nachgedacht wird und zwar nicht also
auch die Argumente wirklich gewogen
werden und man versucht die
Waffensysteme zu verstehen ob sie
wirklich helfen dass man
Geheimdienstinformationen auswertet und
sagt was ist der Schritt zu weit den wir
jetzt nicht mehr gehen können ich denke
das ist das was eine Regierung leisten
sollte natürlich geht es mir und
wahrscheinlich Olaf Scholz in allen
anderen genauso wie allen Menschen und
sieht fürchterliche Bilder und das Herz
kühlt einem rüber also das kann doch
wohl nicht wahr sein da werden wir es
mal richtig mit allem reingehen was wir
haben aber in der Situation kann man
nicht nur emotional entscheiden das ist
die Aufgabe einer Regierung und das
unterscheidet uns vielleicht von
Menschen die im Moment dann freier ihren
Emotionen Folgen können dass wir kühlen
Kopf behalten also die große Sorge ist
ja dass es zu einer Müdigkeit kommt dass
wenigstens auch Frau beerbock aus ist es
Aufgabe der Grünen ist es Aufgabe von
Robert Habeck und Annalena baerbock den
Kanzler und die deutschen wach zu halten
ich denke wenn man über den Krieg
nachdenkt dann wird man nicht nur wach
sondern immer wieder
den in das Erschrecken zurück taumeln
dass uns im Februar März so ergriffen
hat aber wir müssen natürlich ehrlich
sein wir wissen das von uns selbst ich
will mich da gar nicht ausschließen es
gibt Gewöhnung an alles mögliche und
auch die mediale Berichterstattung zieht
einfach weiter und dann sind die
Sommerferien oder der Tankrabatt oder
die Fußball-Bundesliga irgendwann
wichtiger als wie viele Tote jetzt an
dem Tag wieder zu beklagen sind in so
einer Welt lieben wir wir sind Teil
davon und wenn wir das nicht zur
Gewohnheit werden lassen einfach Fall
ist weil wir uns dafür eigentlich
schämen müssen dann müssen wir uns immer
wieder zwingen dass diese ja
strukturelle Gleichgültigkeit die in der
Gesellschaft da ist beziehungsweise die
menschliche Gewöhnung auch an die und
das Gröbste Übel zu hinterfragen und
natürlich sind auch da Politikerinnen
und Politiker in einer besonderen
Verantwortung immer wieder
ein Punkt zu setzen und zu sagen ja man
darf schon feiern man darf sich auch die
Sommerferien freuen aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass wir in einer
besonderen Zeit leben und dann das auch
erklären warum das so ist und wie wir
sie zu einer besseren machen die Ukraine
sorgt sich um Odessa und hier sorgt man
sich um PCK Schwedt haben sie manchmal
die Sorge dass uns die Puste ausgeht
die Puste geht uns nicht aus wir sind
immer noch eins der reichsten Länder der
Welt wir haben eine robuste Wirtschaft
wir sind bisher gut durchgekommen aber
natürlich ist die Situation so dass man
sich Sorgen machen muss und dass viele
Menschen im Alltag Sorgen haben dass die
Energiepreise enorm hoch sind und ich
glaube ja kein Geheimnis aus nicht
geringer werden und zwar erst recht
nicht geringer was das Heizen angeht wir
gucken im Moment alle auf die
Tankstellen die wahre Belastung für die
meisten Bürgerinnen und Bürger kommt mit
der Heizkostenrechnung die
Heizkostenrechnung wird nachgereicht
gegenüber den Preisen die schon da waren
also die Rechnung sind schon geschrieben
wir werden einen dramatischen Anstieg
der Heizkosten erleben und ob da dann
die politischen Maßnahmen ausreichen um
gesellschaftlichen Frieden und das
Gefühl dass es fair in diesem Land
zugeht durchzuhalten das wird die
entscheidende Frage des Herbstes und des
Winters werden da bin ich noch nicht
ganz sicher ich glaube da liegt noch
eine große gesellschaftliche und
politische Aufgabe vor uns
Henry Kissinger hat sich zu Wort
gemeldet und die Ukraine gebeten über
Gebietsabtretungen nachzudenken um das
Friedenswillen macron hat ausgesprochen
dass es keine Demütigung Moskaus geben
darf also die Stimmen mehreren sich
derjenigen die sagen es muss zu einem
baldigen Frieden kommen wer glauben sie
wird den längeren Atem haben Herr Habeck
Russland oder der Westen
danke für dieses Gespräch
und damit sind wir zurück in der Runde
Kathrin Eigendorf ist bei uns Reporterin
des ZDFs den grimmepreis gerade gewonnen
haben sie sind vor zwei Wochen aus Kiel
zurückgekommen Katrin glauben sie um auf
diese zentrale Frage unserer Sendung
heute noch mal zu kommen glauben Sie
dass die Ukraine überhaupt an kriegs-
und an Rückeroberungen der Gebiete noch
glauben dass es die Überzeugung gibt
dass man die Kraft haben kann und die
Kraft weiter haben wird dieser
russischen Armee etwas entgegenzusetzen
also was ich beobachte ist das natürlich
mit dem Verlauf des Krieges und der
wachsenden Zahl auch von zivilen Opfern
auch bei den Ukrainern die Verzweiflung
wächst und die Frage wie viele Opfer
muss man noch bringen und was wir ja
sehen ist ja im Prinzip nur ein
draufblick also wenn man es zum Beispiel
auch mal angucken wie hoch die Verluste
auch von Soldaten und
Territorialverteidigung an der Front im
Donbass ist ich habe heute noch mit
einem Arzt telefoniert der in krematorsk
ist der sagt wir haben so viele
verletzte Soldaten dass wir nicht mal
die versorgen können die Einschüsse in
den Beinen haben die verbluten und zwar
wenig genug Plätze in den Krankenhäusern
haben also das ist die Situation am
Boden aber ich habe bis jetzt bei all
meinen Gesprächen auch mit den
schlimmsten betroffenen Opfern niemanden
gesprochen der gesagt hat wir geben
unser Land Preis und wir müssen uns
jetzt zurückziehen und
ich denke für die meisten Ukrainer für
die große Mehrheit ist es alternativlos
sie wollen Ihr Land nicht verlassen sie
wollen ihr Land verteidigen und sie
sagen im Prinzip haben wir keine andere
Wahl als zu kämpfen weil das was wir
beobachten jetzt ist ja das dass die
russische Armee praktisch wie eine
Feuerwalze über dieses Land
hergeht und es geht ja auch gar nicht
mehr darum Gebiete zu erobern und zu
kontrollieren sondern es ist ein
Vernichtungskrieg ein kesselung und
Vernichtung und Vernichtung vor allem
der Zivilbevölkerung Rückeroberung ihrer
Heimat ist das überhaupt noch möglich
fragen wir uns Roderich Kiesewetter ist
bei uns aus dem Politiker der CDU Herr
Kiesewetter sie waren in Kiew und haben
den Präsident selensky da getroffen und
gesprochen glauben sie dass er mit allem
Realismus denn auch noch einschätzt und
einschätzen kann ob es ein realistisches
Ziel ist das zurückzuerobern was die
Russen sich in diesem Krieg schon
genommen haben
ich halte Präsident selenski Frau Illner
für einen sehr nüchternen Realpolitiker
der eben auch sieht je länger der Krieg
dauert umso mehr wachst auch in der
eigenen politischen Konkurrenz der
Wunsch eben auf nichts zu verzichten und
er hat ein sehr maßvolles sehr maßvolle
Vorstellung über die Zukunft der Ukraine
nämlich die Wiederherstellung der
Grenzen vom Januar also Verzicht auf die
Krim er war vor den furchtbaren
Kriegsverbrechen in Butcher und anderswo
auch bereit auf NATO-Mitgliedschaft zu
verzichten und Neutralität also jemand
der wirklich ein Verhandlungsangebot an
Russland gemacht hat das aber mit
Kriegsverbrechen beantwortet wurde und
wir sollten selensky unterstützen damit
er auch seine Vernunft bewahrt und
gestützt bleibt und eben nicht von
schlimmer Konkurrenz die es in seinem
Land ja noch gibt beseitigt wird vor
einer Woche hieß es aus Kiew der
russischen Armee sei das Rückgrat
gebrochen worden jetzt ist die Lage im
Donbass sehr sehr schwierig auch ein
Zitat waren wir waren auch Sie dazu
optimistisch in Betrachtung dessen was
die Ukraine
jetzt erreicht im Angesicht dieser
organisierten russischen Armee überhaupt
nicht optimistisch und bin es auch nicht
weil die Ukraine ungeheuer abhängig ist
von Waffenlieferungen die meisten Waffen
die geliefert wurden sind verbraucht das
kann ja auch vorhin bei Herrn Harbeck an
und sie brauchen die Unterstützung und
die Gefahr ist eben das klang auch eben
an dass quasi der Krieg in den
Hintergrund gerät sowie der Syrien krieg
ja auch fast eine surifizierung in den
Hintergrund gerät und rifizierung
syrifizierung nenne ich das weil eben
die brutalen Kriege noch Gewöhnung an
den Krieg und auch das rausfallen aus
den Medien und ich sehe halt die große
Sorge dass die Ukraine irgendwann in
einen scheinbaren der Krieg in einen
scheinbar Normalzustand kommt und
Russland hat die Kraft hat auch die
Reserven und hier geht es schlichtweg um
militärische Gewalt und wer den
stärkeren politischen Willen hat und die
ausreichenden Reserven und da brauchen
wir die Unterstützung heute war der
ukrainische radarpräsident Stefan Schuck
da und hat sehr stark geworben der
Bundestag unterstützt ja die
Bundesregierung der Parlamentspräsident
war da heute und der unterstützt auch
unseren Antrag und wir unterstützen ja
auch vom Bundestag die Bundesregierung
und da gibt sicherlich noch besser
Verbesserungsbedarf wir diskutieren
darüber Putins Armee erleidet große
Verluste dass es auch richtig aber sie
sieht und sie kommt voran und das gucken
wir uns vielleicht noch mal an
Putin darf seinen Krieg nicht gewinnen
schon jetzt hat er alle seine
strategischen Ziele verfehlt so die
Meinung des Kanzlers nach über drei
Monaten Krieg
aber stimmt das überhaupt
ja Kiew hat im Ansturm standgehalten
doch sonst färbt sich die Karte vor
allem im Osten und Süden der Ukraine
Brot
sie setzen alles ein die Lage im Donbass
ist sehr schwierig
Putins erstes Ziel scheint erreichbar
die Handelsmöglichkeiten der Ukraine auf
dem Seeweg zu kappen und die
industrielle Basis im Donbass zu erobern
so wie die Karte heute aussieht bliebe
ein westukrainischer Rumpfstaat einer
der für sein Überleben langfristig
abhängig von ausländischer Hilfe wäre
nochmal Kathrin Eigendorf das war vorhin
falsch zitiert von mir selenski sagt
heute selbst 20 Prozent also ein Fünftel
des Landes ist mittlerweile russisch
besetzt viele wünschen natürlich der
Ukraine den Erfolg was wenn es den nicht
gibt
ja das ist eine gute Frage wir müssen
erstmal definieren was Erfolg ist
ich glaube wenn wir uns die Situation
heute ansehen und uns Vladimir Putin
ansehen und der kommt in unserer ganzen
Betrachtung immer viel zu kurz ja was
sind seine Ziele seine Ziele sind ja
nicht nur dass er der Ukraine den Krieg
erklärt hat sondern hat er im Prinzip in
diesem Krieg dem Westen uns den Krieg
erklärt und das glaube ich macht ist
noch mal zu einem ganz besonderen Krieg
deswegen befürchte ich keine
surifizierung weil dieser Krieg geht uns
viel zu sehr an
wir können es nicht zulassen dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg verliert in dem
Sinne das Wladimir Putin dieses Land
komplett vereinnahmt dass er so viel
Gebietsgewinne erzielt dass er von dort
aus im Prinzip auch im Rest der Welt
operieren kann wir haben ja gesehen dass
im Prinzip diese Abkommen die unter
unserem Druck auch entstanden sind Minz
1 und 2 die Ukraine in eine Situation
gebracht haben die sie ja so verletzlich
gemacht hat jetzt woher kommen denn die
Truppen die auf Odessa zugehen von der
Krim
wo sind denn die Stärken der russischen
Seite natürlich über den bonbass also
die von Russland kontrollierten Gebiete
der Ukraine anzugreifen also ich denke
wir sollten die Ukraine nicht dazu ja im
Prinzip bewegen wegen meinen
halbherzigen Frieden einzugehen weil ein
nur ein stabiler Frieden
kann auch für uns die Welt sicherer
machen Johannes Warwick ist bei uns und
das ist so etwas wie sein Stichwort
Politikwissenschaftler Professor für
internationale Beziehungen an der Uni in
Halle sie haben sehr früher Professor
Warwick dafür plädiert Anfang März schon
unbedingt auf Verhandlungen zu gehen und
sehr schnell nach einer
Verhandlungslösung zu schauen und sind
dafür nicht nur von dem ukrainischen
Botschafter beschimpft worden haben sie
die Ukraine zu früh aufgegeben mal
unabhängig davon dass es eben wirklich
auch Erfolge der Russen gibt nein es
geht überhaupt nicht um Aufgeben der
Ukraine natürlich hat die Ukraine unsere
volle Solidarität verdient das ist
überhaupt gar keine Frage die Frage ist
nur was ist in dieser Situation
erreichbar und da plädiere ich für
Nüchternheit und für Realismus und ich
glaube es ist nicht verantwortbar die
Ukraine gewissermaßen mit unseren
Waffenlieferungen immer weiter in die
Lage zu bringen einer einen
aussichtslosen Kampf zu führen und
natürlich muss die Ukraine selber
definieren was aussichtslos ist aber
weil wir involviert sind mit
Waffenlieferungen haben wir den
Schlüssel gewissermaßen schon in der
Hand und immer nur zu sagen das sind die
ukrainischen Vorstellungen das müssen
die selber entscheiden das greift zu
kurz wir haben eigene Interessen und
unser oberstes Interesse muss und sollte
sein ein Krieg mit Russland zu vermeiden
und das zweite Interesse daraus
abgeleitet ist dass wir die Ukraine
helfen müssen wenn aber beides nicht
zusammen geht dann bin ich dafür dass
wir die Lage nüchtern bewerten und auch
akzeptieren dass dieser Konflikt im
Moment nicht lösbar ist wir müssen ihn
einfrieren und das ist schwer genug und
ein Einfrieren geht nicht mit immer mehr
Waffenlieferung das ist der falsche Weg
und sie haben gefragt nach
Kriegsmüdigkeit das ist ein sehr
merkwürdiger begriff ich bin kriegsmüde
weil ich keinen Krieg will und ich
glaube jeder vernünftige Mensch ist in
dem Sinne kriegsmüde wir müssen der
Ukraine helfen ja aber die Frage ist mit
welchem Mitteln wir das tun sollen ein
aussichtslosen Kampf zu unterstütz macht
keinen Sinn Herr Kiesewetter hat schon
den Kopf geschüttet wir fragen mal
lieber Kevin Kühnert den Generalsekretär
der SPD würden sie sich der These von
Herrn Warwick anschließen das im Grunde
sich diese beiden Ziele ausschließen
keinen Krieg mit Russland zu wollen und
die Ukraine aber unterstützen zu wollen
so habe ich ihn jetzt gar nicht zwingend
verstanden wir sehen ja im Moment und
seit drei Monaten dass es sehr wohl
zusammen geht wir unterstützen auch
militärisch die Ukraine ohne dass wir
bis hierhin Teil dieses Krieges geworden
wären oder auch nur kurz davor wären das
ist ja auch ein Bekenntnis was die
Bundesregierung vom ersten Tag bei jeder
Gelegenheit abgibt wir werden alles
dafür tun weder bewusst noch unbewusst
durch Fahrlässigkeit in diesen Krieg
hineingezogen zu werden und trotzdem hat
es uns das bis hierhin ermöglicht auch
sehr robust die Ukraine zu unterstützen
und im zweiten Schritt würde ich auch
sagen ich warne davor ein
Schwarz-Weiß-Bild zu zeichnen und so zu
tun als bestünde nur die Variante
zwischen jetzt sofort verhandeln oder
kämpfen bis zum letzten Mann das hat
jetzt hier niemand gesagt Kontakt aber
so wird das ja manchmal ein bisschen
insinuiert auch der ukrainische
Präsident Herr selenski selbst hat ja
längst gesagt dass natürlich das
Ergebnis dieses Krieges und ein wirklich
verlässlicher langfristiger Frieden
ausschließlich auf dem Verhandlungsweg
erreicht werden kann es gibt nur
Voraussetzung wie es in jeder freien
Gesellschaft der Fall ist wann eine
Gesellschaft für sich selber zu dem
Schluss kommt zu sagen jetzt können wir
uns an den Verhandlungstisch setzen
jetzt haben wir eine Grundlage auf der
zunächst die waffenschweigen können und
wir vielleicht langsam anfangen können
uns anzunähern und das ist auf Grundlage
der Karte die wir eben gesehen haben
nach Auffassung der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer und ich glaube das können viele
nachvollziehen aktuell nicht der Fall so
und dann sind wir dabei dass gestern der
Bundeskanzler neue Waffenlieferungen
angekündigt hat mal wieder die dauern
jetzt auch Wochen im Falle dieses
flugabwehrsystems sogar Monate Herr
Kühnert ist Olaf Scholz ein
ankündigungskanzler Nein und das wäre er
dann wenn er behauptet hätte das kommt
jetzt alles Morgen und dann kommt es gar
nicht wir wussten doch von vornherein
bei der Panzerhaubitze 2000 das daran
Ausbildungs stattfinden muss das immer
kommuniziert worden die findet ja jetzt
aktuell bei uns statt und irgendwann
wird das ausgebildete militärische
personalaus der Ukraine und das Gerät in
die Ukraine gehen und so ist es auch mit
dem Flugabwehr Geparden auch an dem wird
ausgebildet und während einige
respektiere das jetzt seine Meinung aber
während einige sagen das dauere alles
viel zu lange und sei Verzögerung sehe
ich Menschen aus der Truppe in
Deutschland selbst die lange Zeit an
einem Flugabwehr Geparden gearbeitet und
dort auch ausgebildet haben und die sich
in sozialen Netzwerken dahingehend
äußern dass sie sagen Ausbildung in drei
Wochen an dem Gerät das kann ich mir
kaum vorstellen das halte ich für sehr
risikobehaftet ich kann das als
militärischer Laie überhaupt gar nicht
bewerten aber ich lese und höre beides
und denke mir vielleicht ist es doch
nicht ganz so einfach und schwarz-weiß
wie manche sich das vorstellen Eva
Quadbeck ist bei uns Journalistin
Leiterin des Hauptstadtbüros und
stellvertretender Chefredakteur vom
netzwerkrecherche
interessanterweise hat ich soll
redaktionsnetzwerk Entschuldigung also
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland heißt es
korrekterweise wir sind bei der
interessanten Frage ob ein Kollege von
der Berliner Zeitung vielleicht recht
haben könnte wenn er sagt das ist ein
Trick des Kanzlers immer dann wenn etwas
versprochen ist nicht geliefert wird
dann zieht er was neues aus der Tasche
welchen Eindruck hat die
stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom
redaktionsnetzwerk
also ich habe nicht den Eindruck dass
Olaf Scholz die ganze Republik veräppelt
weil das wäre ja das wenn der Kollege an
dieser Stelle recht hat aber Olaf Scholz
hat von Beginn des Krieges an immer
defensiv agiert also Deutschland hat
zwar jetzt eine beachtliche Liste an
Waffen präsentiert die bereits geliefert
worden sind aber es gab beispielsweise
eine Antwort der Bundesregierung auf
eine kleine Anfrage der Linken da es mal
nach vier Wochen Krieg abgefragt worden
wie viel habt ihr geliefert und da kam
bei Deutschland die Summe von 190
Millionen Euro zusammen das kleine
Estland hatte schon 200 Millionen
geliefert und die Amerikaner Waffen im
Wert von 3,5 Milliarden Euro also
einfach nur um so diese Dimension mal zu
zeigen es ist nicht so dass Deutschland
nichts tut aber wir sind da auf jeden
Fall im hinteren Feld wenn es darum geht
aus unseren Worten dann auch tatsächlich
Taten werden zu lassen und Deutschland
hat sich ja auch verbal solidarisch
immer sehr stark an die Seite der
Ukraine gestellt und uns war von Anfang
an klar dass eben nicht nur die paar
Quadratmeter Kilometer im Donders
verteidigt werden so wie Henry Kissinger
das genannt hat sondern dass es
natürlich um ein sehr viel größeres Ziel
geht das ist auch darum geht den
Gedanken der Demokratie und der Freiheit
mitzuverteidigen und da waren wir auf
jeden Fall mit den Worten größer als mit
den Taten die wir haben folgen lassen
aber natürlich kann man nicht sagen es
sei nichts geschehen und auch an der
Formulierung des Kanzlers die wir gerade
schon diskutiert haben dass er sagt die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren also
Minimalziel sie darf nicht in die Lage
geraten müssen dass sie kapitulieren
muss
auf diesen Niveau bewegt sich
Deutschland und auf diesem Niveau
liefert Deutschland eben auch Waffen und
Deutschland liefert eben nicht auf dem
Niveau Waffen die Ukraine soll Siegen
das hat der Habeck ja eben recht gut
erklärt dass das ja auch ein nach oben
offenes Ziel ist das heißt wir erfüllen
tatsächlich längst nicht alle Wünsche
und Bedürfnis Ukraine gestern hat der
Bundeskanzler versucht sich zu wehren
haben Sie den Eindruck dass er in die
Vorhand kommt also das war auf jeden
Fall ein sehr bemerkenswerter Auftritt
dass der Oppositionsführer März dass der
Attacke kann und das wäre das auch bei
jeder Gelegenheit tut das war klar der
Auftritt von Olaf Scholz der ja dann
auch dem etwas entgegensetzen musste und
wollte war aus meiner Sicht überraschend
aber das hat man bei Scholz auch schon
immer mal wieder gesehen dass wenn er
mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht durchaus
dann was nachlegen kann und in die
Offensive geht das hat er gestern getan
das war überzeugend nur jetzt ist
natürlich ganz wichtig dass das was er
da angekündigt hat eben auch umgesetzt
wird und wenn es etwas dauert dass das
Luftabwehrsystem
dass die Ukraine ja wirklich dankbar
entgegennimmt wenn das jetzt noch
tatsächlich bis Oktober oder November
dauert bis Deutschland das liefern kann
dann wird zwischendrin werden sicherlich
noch andere Lieferungen auch jenseits
dessen was jetzt schon öffentlich ist
paar Wochen wurde notwendig sein wenn
die Ukraine den Krieg nicht gewinnt dann
auch deshalb weil wie sie sagen der
Bundeskanzler Herr Kiesewetter nicht
will dass die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnt
ich habe die Befürchtung unlängst
geäußert und mache das an drei
Beobachtungen fest und ich glaube dass
gestern schon auch eine Wende im
Auftreten des Kanzlers zu spüren ist
erstens die Umsetzung des
bundestagsbeschlusses ermöglicht ihm die
schon seit Mitte Mai verfügbar nein
Mitte April verfügbaren knapp 50 Mörder
und knapp 50 Leopard 1 zu liefern
stattdessen werden die so ein Marder
kostet anderthalb Millionen Euro an
Griechenland gegeben und dort werden
Panzer die 1994 zum Stückpreis von
25.000 D-Mark damals verkauft wurden aus
NVA Beständen an Griechenland ersetzt da
freut sich natürlich Griechenland dass
sie in sehr altes Gerät dann für
anderthalb Millionen Euro pro Stück
ersetzt bekommt aber es hilft der
Ukraine nicht fast 60 Jahre alte
Schützenpanzer zu bekommen und der
Bundestag beschlossen da stehen wir ja
dahinter das haben wir mit über 500
Stimmen hinbekommen ermöglicht es ja
dass die Bundesregierung Marder und
Leopard liefert und ich weiß dass das
Außenministerium und auch das
Wirtschaftsministerium das befürwortet
haben und da wünsche ich mir dass der
Kanzler hilft damit die Ukraine in eine
Verhandlungsposition gebracht wird die
sie militärisch überzeugen dann auch
glaubwürdig am Tisch vertreten kann und
wenn wir wollen dass die Ukraine es
schafft dann wäre es doch einfacher
statt komplizierte ringtausche zu machen
das unmittelbar und das sind ja keine
hoch innovativen neuen Systeme das
unmittelbar an die Ukraine zu geben
statt wirklich 60 Jahre alte BMP das
bringt das ist unser Land nicht würdig
muss ich sagen wollen sie sagen dass
Parlament ist weitergegangen und sie
stoßen sich auch an der Formulierung des
Bundeskanzlers dass die Ukraine Bestand
haben soll es werden noch zwei andere
Punkte die ich für richtig hielte wenn
der Bundeskanzler jetzt auch in
Vorbereitung des EU-Gipfels gesagt hätte
Perspektive für die ukrainische
Bevölkerung wir setzen uns dafür ein
dass ein Kandidatenstatus kommt damit
Zuversicht der Ukraine sie wollen ja
Teil der Europäischen Union werden in 20
Jahren
ich finde es auch gut EU und nicht NATO
und der dritte Aspekt ist schlichtweg
dass die Ukraine weiß wir wollen dass
Sie die Souveränität und Integrität der
Grenzen von Januar diesen Jahres
wiederherstellen kann dass wir das
unterstützen definieren muss sie selber
aber sie Lenski hat das auch beim Besuch
von Friedrich Merz in Kiew gesagt dass
das das eigentliche Ziel ist vor den
Kriegsverbrechen die sie gesehen haben
er war weg wir sind wieder bei dieser
Frage kann man der Ukraine muss man der
Ukraine nicht ermöglichen mit den besten
zur Verfügung stehenden Waffen die
bestmögliche Situation für die von Ihnen
angesprochenen Verhandlungen zu
erreichen das hört sich natürlich
sympathisch an aber denken wir das doch
mal zu Ende was bedeutet das wer hat die
eskalationsfähigkeit in diesem Konflikt
in diesem Krieg ich denke die liegt auf
russischer Seite und nicht weil ich mir
das wünsche sondern weil das eine
nüchterne Beschreibung der Lage ist das
heißt dass wir derzeit machen ist ein
Ritt auf der Rasierklinge wir liefern
Waffen versuchen dass die Ukraine dem
russischen Angriff der russischen
Aggression Bestand hält sehen aber das
Russland bereit und in der Lage ist
gegen zu eskalieren das heißt wir lassen
diesen Konflikt im Prinzip länger
blutiger werden und ich finde das ist
keine moralisch höherwertige Position
als nüchtern sich diesen Konflikt
anzuschauen und mit Bescheidenheit mit
Augenmaß daran zu gehen und zu sagen es
gibt Kriegsziele die die Russen
erreichen werden und sie werden jeden
Preis dafür einsetzen weil es um ihre
vitalen Interessen geht und wir haben im
übrigen versäumt diese russische
Perspektive im Vorfeld dieses Krieges
besser zu lesen das heißt ich bin nach
wie vor davon überzeugt dass es die
Möglichkeit gegeben hätte ein
Interessenausgleich mit Russland
hinzubekommen und wenn jetzt Menschen
wie Henry Kissinger das ist jetzt genau
ja richtig aber wenn jetzt Menschen
Ausgleich mit Russland verstanden
nein das ist doch keine Frage das ist
doch natürlich dass wir darüber
nachdenken mussten dass wir
gewissermaßen überlappende Einflusszonen
in dieser komplizierten
Regionalisierung der Ukraine
Begriffe aggressiven totalitären Regime
zu tun wo sehen sie da bitte den
Ausgleich jetzt durch den Krieg wird
alles schlechter gar keine Zeit wissen
sie das denn das ist doch Kollegen
Kollegen darf ich Ausreden Frau
Eickendorf wenn die Kollegen wenn kluge
Kollegen wie John mörshahn war
amerikanischer Politik wir sind aber
genau das sagen dass wir einfach nicht
richtig gelesen haben das ist bei der
Ukraine gewissermaßen ein Sonderfall ist
der in russischer Perspektive einfach
anders zu sehen ist als andere Staaten
nicht dass wir akzeptieren dass die
Souveränität der Ukraine in Frage
gestellt wird aber dass wir hätten
akzeptieren müssen und das ist nicht
hätte hätte Fahrradkette sondern bietet
auch den Schlüssel für die Lösung jetzt
dass wir akzeptieren müssen dass die
Ukraine nicht vollends ins westliche
Lager kippt und wir tun so als ob wir in
der Lage sind habe ich Ausreden nein wir
tun so als ob wir in der Lage sind das
zu verhindern wir wollen es aber nicht
weil wir nicht bereit sind für die
Ukraine in den Krieg zu ziehen das heißt
es bleiben nur mildere Mittel im Moment
sind das Waffenlieferungen wir werden
aber glaube ich damit kein dauerhaft
Erfolg haben sondern wir werden Erfolg
haben wenn es wieder gelingt mit
Russland einen sozusagen Ausgleich
hinzubekommen der auf Gleichgewicht
beruht und das sind Gedanken in der
deutschen Debatte die völlig diffamiert
sind und ich bin gewiss kein Putin
Freund oder Putin verstehe aber ich
glaube um diesen Konflikt zu lösen
müssen wir in diese Richtung denken und
Leute wie Henry Kissinger machen genau
diese Argumente und bis vor kurzem ist
man noch über alle hergefallen aber
jetzt beginnt der winzig zu drehen und
viele merken dass in diesem Krieg für
keinen was zu gewinnen ist und wir
einfach einen nüchternen vielleicht auch
schmutzigen Interessenausgleich
hinbekommen müssen und wir haben Mittel
und Wege die Kabine in diese Richtung
gewissermaßen ich will nicht sagen zu
lenken das muss die Ukraine selber
wissen aber wenn wir keine Waffen mehr
liefern müssen dann wäre die Ukraine
gewissermaßen verloren daraus resultiert
eine Verantwortung dass wir der Ukraine
auch raten welchen Weg Sie gehen kann
und das könnte Schlimmeres verhindern
ein Einfrieren ist also das Gebot der
Stunde die Alternative ist eine
Eskalation im Konflikt man ja
eingeblendet
haben dann ist es doch dass wir zu viel
easement-politik gegenüber Putin gemacht
haben also das ist ja nur der Schuh den
sich die Deutschen jetzt anziehen müssen
dass wir Putin komplett falsch
eingeschätzt haben was seine
Verlässlichkeit angeht und was auch die
Möglichkeit angeht tatsächlich seine
Aggression einzudämmen und wenn sie von
Einflusszonen sprechen dann lassen sie
sich ja komplett auf die
imperialistische Argumentation von Putin
ein wir leben doch in einer Welt in der
es nicht um Einflusszonen geht sondern
wir leben wir wollen in einer
bipolaren Welt in der natürlich jeder
Staat seine Souveränität hat und darüber
bestimmen kann in welchem politischen
System erlebt und da können wir uns
nicht auf diese Linie von Putin begeben
und dann sagen wir machen einen Deal mit
ihm mit Putin kann man keinen Deal mehr
machen er hat einen Angriffskrieg gegen
ein Land mitten in eure führter mitten
in Europa mit Putin ist nicht mehr zu
reden ist natürlich muss man diese
gesprächsfäden aufrecht erhalten aber
die sind doch nur dafür da um noch
Eskalation und das Schlimmste zu
vermeiden aber einen verhandlungsfrieden
den wird es mit Putin sicherlich nicht
geben und noch mal ein
Abkommen zu machen wie beispielsweise
minskke das habe ich damals für richtig
gehalten aber heute weiß man es hat
einfach nicht funktioniert es hat den
Konflikt zwar eingefroren aber es ist
klar das Putin in einem Moment in dem er
wieder Stärke hat dort weitermachen wird
und trotzdem
Warwick jetzt noch mal antwortet
vielleicht hören wir mal dass das durch
ist eine Position ist die nicht nur von
Henry Kissinger geteilt wird auch wenn
die Politiker mal ganz grundsätzlich
anders zunächst äußerten sich
argumentieren wir müssen alles was in
unserer Macht steht tun um der Ukraine
zum Sieg zu verhelfen
das heißt die Ukraine muss gewinnen
Europa die freie Welt und die Ukraine
muss gewinnen
Politiker im moralrausch
aber kann man mit moralischen Kategorien
auch Kriege beenden und da allein die
Ukraine als Opfer entscheiden wann die
Waffen schweigen
beim Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos sagte
Henry Kissinger
alles was über den Frontverlauf vor dem
24 Februar hinausginge wäre nicht länger
ein Freiheitskrieg der Ukraine sondern
ein Krieg gegen Russland
er hoffe dass die Ukraine bei
Verhandlungen so weise sein wird wie
sieht derzeit heldenhaft ist
ist es das was der Kanzler in so vielen
Worten nicht sagen kann oder will
unser wichtigster europäischer
Verbündeter denkt ähnlich
und warnt
[Musik]
das geht nur ohne den anderen
auszuschließen und ohne Demütigung
nochmal nachfrage Herr Warwick würden
Sie sagen dass nicht nur macron sondern
auch Olaf Scholz in ihren Augen und in
dieser Hinsicht Politiker und
Staatsführer sind die sehr wohl andere
Interessen ihrer Länder auch nicht nur
zur Kenntnis nehmen sondern in den
Vordergrund rücken und eben sehr
zurückhaltend und erst mal abwartend
sind ich hoffe das es gibt aber
sozusagen keine klaren Signale dafür ich
hoffe aber dass Scholz klug genug ist
zusammen mit macron und übrigens auch
mit Draghi es ist ja gewissermaßen ein
deutsch-französisch-italienischer Ansatz
der offenkundig die Dinge etwas anders
sieht als die Amerikaner die Polen oder
die Briten das heißt da gibt es
unterschiedliche strategische
Vorstellungen Scholz äußert das nicht
offen und ich weiß nicht was er denkt
ich sitze nicht im Kanzleramt und berate
ihn nicht aber er äußert das nicht offen
weil er zu Recht auch sagt dass
Geschlossenheit gewissermaßen ein sehr
sehr hohes Gut ist und Deutschland wäre
wahrscheinlich nicht gut beraten da
jetzt öffentlich vorzubrechen ich hoffe
doch sehr dass hinter den Kulissen diese
interessensunterschiede die ich
angedeutet habe auch in die Waagschale
geworfen werden und da was besseres
dabei rauskommt als wenn man nur
polnische oder amerikanische Positionen
in seine Strategie einpreist Herr
Kühnert wichtige Frage an sie glauben
sie dass Kissinger ausspricht was viele
in der SPD denken
das so wie wir ihn gerade lesen denn ein
kissenger hier glaube ich das nicht denn
es entspricht ja zum Beispiel auch nicht
dem was wir gemeinsam mit breiter
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag Ende
April in diesem Antrag beschlossen haben
der ja viel mehr ist als ein schwere
waffenantrag als der jetzt gerne mal
apostrophiert wird das ist eine
mehrseitige Analyse der Lage die
übrigens auch gut durchblicken lässt
welchen Perspektive die Mehrheit der
Abgeordneten im Deutschen Bundestag auch
für einen Frieden und für eine
Souveränität der Ukraine sieht da geht
klar aus diesem Antrag hervor dass es
ein Selbstbestimmungsrecht auch in
Zeiten des Krieges gibt und niemand von
uns sagen kann was der richtige Ausweg
für die Ukraine ist außer die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer selbst damit
stehen wir übrigens nicht alleine
sondern das ist das was jetzt auch der
amerikanische Präsident diese Woche
gerade in seinem Beitrag in der New York
Times noch mal dargelegt hat ja
wirklich sollen wir das wirklich glauben
da werden jetzt auch entsprechende
Raketensysteme hingeschickt die eine
Reichweite korrigieren Sie mich von 30
bis 60 Kilometer haben sie sollen nicht
auf das Land auf der auf russisches
Territorium reichen können anderes Gerät
was das könnte und was deutlich größere
Reichweite
nein es geht darum deutlich zu
unterstreichen dass wir es ernst meinen
wenn wir sagen ein Krieg wiederum ein
umgekehrt imperialer Krieg gegen Putins
Russland ist eben auch nicht intendiert
uns geht es einzig und allein aber das
ist ja schon eine große Sache um die
Integrität der Ukraine in ihren
völkerrechtlich legitimen Grenzen zu
denen wir uns bekennen und die einzig
zufriedenstellende Lösung für die breite
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag aber
glaube ich auch in unserer Gesellschaft
ist dass die russischen Truppen sich aus
diesem Land in dem sie militärisch
nichts zu suchen haben sich zurückziehen
dass das natürlich nicht wiederum
bedeutet dass man daraus das Recht
ableitet jetzt einfach alles
niederzuschießen und dafür alles was wir
irgendwo finden können bei Rheinmetall
oder sonstwo zur Verfügung stellen das
erschließt sich auch von alleine wir
haben ja auch vor dem 24 februar die
Position vertreten dass die russische
Armee nichts auf der Krim zu suchen hat
ohne dass wir daraus geschlussfolgert
hätten Herr selenski sollte morgen seine
Truppen in Bewegung setzen um
militärisch die erobern manchmal muss
man Feststellung machen ohne dass daraus
eine einfache Antwort für eine Handlung
noch dazu militärische Art von und was
macron sagt glauben sie spielt im Denken
von Olaf Scholz eine Rolle darauf
aufmerksam zu machen dass es keine
Demütigung des anderen geben darf und
dass es am Ende auch auf Verhandlungen
hinausläuft sie sagen das selbst ich
würde da nicht von Demütigung sprechen
weil die Gemütslage von Herrn Putin
jetzt zu sezieren in der Öffentlichkeit
ist weiß ich nicht wie ergiebe ich das
am Ende ist aber am Ende ist das ja nur
eine andere Umschreibung von wir wollen
nicht Kriegspartei werden wir wollen
keine Handlung vollziehen die nach dem
Völkerrecht aber auch nicht de facto
durch Handlungen und handlungsketten die
sich ergeben dazu führt dass wir
hineingezogen werden und das beinhaltet
in einem Krieg mit einem autoritären
Herrscher mit der imperialen und und
militärisches Gehabe an den Tag liegt
leider auch dass man hin und wieder
erwägen muss zumindest wie könnte seine
Reaktion ausfallen nicht um das zum
Maßstab des eigenen Handelns durch und
durch zu machen aber um sich nicht
vorwerfen zu lassen fahrlässig zu
handeln das schon wenn der Donbass fällt
dann könnten die Ukraine dann könnten
auch die Osteuropäer sagen Deutschland
hat daran eine Mitschuld zu Recht
also erstmal gilt es ja dafür zu sorgen
dass das nicht passiert und die
Waffensysteme auf die sie eben
angespielt haben die Raketenwerfer die
jetzt mit der besagten Reichweite
geliefert werden so habe ich es
verstanden sollen ja eine Art
Waffengleichheit darstellen russische
Seite verfügt dort im Don Bass über
vergleichbares von der Feuerkraft und
der Reichweite her Gerät weshalb wir
eine Asymmetrie sozusagen vor Ort haben
die Rücken dort voran die können die
Infrastruktur und auch die militärischen
Stellung der Ukraine zerstören ohne dass
die ukrainische Seite mit vergleichbar
geringem Aufwand sich dabei verteidigen
könnte hier geht es also darum zumindest
erstmal einen Stoppschild aufzustellen
so interpretiere ich die Ankündigung der
jetzt
angekündigten Lieferung an dieser Stelle
so weit ich das überblicken kann und das
scheint mir plausibel zu sein im Rahmen
dessen was bislang unsere
unterstützungsziele für die tragen wir
offensichtlich erfolgreich ab dann
Oktober weil auch das wird ja dauern wer
kann denn jetzt
diese Wette eigentlich nennenswert die
Ukraine unterstützen silensky sagt Tag
für Tag was wir jetzt brauchen sind
Waffen und die kommen nicht an wer kann
das jetzt und wie weit werden die
Amerikaner da gehen vielleicht auch noch
als Republik offenbarek die Amerikaner
unterstützen massiv sie sind ja auch
eine der Schutzmächte der Ukraine
genauso wie die Briten aus dem
Budapester Abkommen den Ukraine war ja
mal nuklear macht hat die Waffen
abgegeben und bekam dann das Budapester
Abkommen genau in der großen Hoffnung
stabile Sicherheit zu haben und das ist
auch unsere Verantwortung bei nukleare
Abrüstung damit nicht mehr möglich ist
aber wir helfen könnte wäre Deutschland
durch Marder durch Leopard leicht zu
bedienen aber wir geben das in einen
aufwendigen Ringtausch oder liefern über
Griechenland dann wirklich veraltete
Systeme da hat Deutschland eine Aufgabe
und ich glaube vom Bundestag aus haben
wir da der Bundesregierung den
Rückenwind gegeben das zweite ist aber
die Wirkung nach außen wie wollen wir
eine Marokko oder in Ägypten sagen dass
sie Menschenrechte einhalten sollen dass
wir Sie im Zweifel unterstützen dass sie
gute Regierungsführung leisten sollen
wenn Sie sehen dass ein Land wie die
Ukraine das gerne Teil der Europäischen
Union sein will scheitert aufgrund
unserer Vorbehalte solche Länder werden
sich künftig nicht an der EU orientieren
sondern gleich am systemischen
Wettbewerbe der nicht genau in die
Bücher schaut und das ist China also wir
haben da auch und das ist der Kernpunkt
wo ich ein farbig widerspreche die
Wirkung nach außen in andere Teile der
Welt ich bin als Außenpolitiker sehr
viel unterwegs ist schon eine fatale
weil sie die Frage stellen wie geht ihr
mit der Ukraine um und unsere Aufgabe
ist jetzt nicht für die Ukraine den
Krieg zu führen überhaupt nicht da sind
wir glaube ich zusammen aber unsere
Aufgabe ist die Ukraine zu befähigen
dass sie ihre Unabhängigkeit
wiederherstellen kann und dafür auch die
Waffenlieferung die Frage ist ist das
ein realistisches Ziel die Ukraine zu
befähigen dort kann man unterschiedliche
Auffassung sein wenn ihre Auffassung
stimmt dann könnte es sich lohnen mit
immer mehr und immer schwereren Waffen
gewissermaßen ein gleich leicht
Aufschluss aufrecht zu halten ich
persönlich habe eine andere Einschätzung
ich glaube dass dieser Krieg nicht durch
Waffenlieferung beendet werden kann
sondern durch politische Lösungen
anschließend und nicht das ist die Frage
jetzt wie die Reihenfolge ist und sie
haben völlig recht das bisher politische
Lösungen gescheitert sind auch weil
Russland nicht dazu bereit war aber wir
müssen weiter Druck natürlich auf
Russland ausüben mit allem was wir haben
aber nicht mit ausschließlich Waffen und
diese Diskussion um immer mehr Waffen
führt im in eine Eskalation im
Verhältnis mit Russland wenn irgendwann
ein Punkt kommt wofür Russland wirklich
aus unseren Waffenlieferungen nicht aus
unseren aber aus den amerikanischen
Waffenlieferungen eine Bedrohung ihrer
Interessen gewissermaßen entstehen
sollte soweit ist es noch nicht dann
wird Russland eskalieren und am Ende
kann nur Russland auch nuklear
eskalieren das sollten wir nicht
vergessen andere gilt ja gegebenenfalls
auch wenn man sich jetzt auf diesen
ihren Friedensschluss einließe und den
auch in einem Moment schlösse in dem es
für die Ukraine von großem Schaden dann
sollen die anderen Länder drumherum
einfach sich so lange zurücklehnen und
warten ob sie die nächsten sind nein gar
nicht es kann doch keine Rede davon sein
dass das schwache sozusagen russische
Militär jetzt irgendwie im Baltikum
zündet nach Polen zieht und morgen in
Westberlin sind das ist doch eine völlig
abwegige Vorstellung Moldau ist eine
riesen Gefahr gar keine Frage eine
riesige Frage und deswegen hängt auch so
viel davon ab was jetzt mit Odessa
passiert und wir müssen natürlich
wirklich sehr sehr viel dafür tun dass
Odessa nicht das nächste Kriegsziel ist
weil dann würde das russische Ziel
gewissermaßen umgesetzt dass die Ukraine
ihre Existenz verliert wenn sie vom
Schwarzen Meer abgeschnitten ist das
wäre ein Desaster und deswegen ist jetzt
auch der Zeitpunkt noch mal mit mehr
Energie Druck zu politischen Lösung zu
machen und ich glaube nicht dass das mit
mehr Waffenlieferung gelingt sondern mit
der Bereitschaft zum Interessenausgleich
wir haben noch nicht darüber geredet
dass ein Baustein sein kann dass die
Ukraine einen neutraler
Staat wird der nicht eindeutig im
westlichen Lager sich verortet und
Russland nicht denkt wenn man jetzt
gewissermaßen eine ein Status Quo
absichert dann ist es übermorgen doch so
weit dass die Ukraine erst in die EU und
dann in die NATO nein das ist der
falsche Weg wir brauchen eine andere
Architektur
sie sagen aber das soll eine
Finanzierung was ich zugestehe das ist
doch ein völlig falsches Wedding sie tun
so als ob der jetzige Weg Erfolg hätte
der hat doch keinen Erfolg das ist
bisher im Desaster geendet das ist doch
der Punkt
nämlich das eine durchaus differenzierte
Stimmung die es mal gab in der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung vor einigen
Jahren insbesondere vor 2014 zur Frage
wie westlich solle man sich eigentlich
orientieren und beinhaltet das dann
irgendwann NATO-Mitgliedschaft oder
zumindest EU-Mitgliedschaft dass diese
Stimmung bei den Menschen die heute noch
zweifelsfrei auf ukrainischem
Territorium Leben immer weiter und jetzt
so ziemlich final gekippt ist also wie
soll dieses Volk was das erlitten hat
im Westen gehörig was ich eh schon
mehrheitlich und mittlerweile extrem
also mit absoluter Mehrheit zugehörig
fühlt welche Perspektive soll auch
emotional für die darin liegen ein wie
auch immer gearteten neutralen Status
dort einzunehmen nach dem was sie erlebt
haben machen der Ukraine falsche
Hoffnung sozusagen in Reihe wir haben
das ist angefangen vor dem Krieg da
haben wir falsche Hoffnung gemacht jetzt
machen wir auch wieder falsche Hoffnung
ich glaube man sollte mal aussprechen
dass das nicht in unserem Interesse
liegen kann dass die Ukraine
gewissermaßen schnell in die Europäische
Union kommt und wir dann die Grenze ein
Stück weit mehr des alten
Ost-West-Konfliktes an Russland
verschoben haben
das ist nicht der Schlüssel für die
Lösung sondern der Schlüssel für die
Lösung ist ein ich sage es noch mal es
ist unpopulär war ein
Interessenausgleich mit Russland und das
heißt nicht die Ukraine zu opfern aber
wir sollten doch hier nicht ich wünsche
mir was spielen sondern von den
realpolitischen Begebenheiten ausgeht
gründlich geschaut worden die Putin vor
diesem Krieg in Richtung Washington und
Westen und in Richtung NATO geschickt
hatte und da hat er ja nicht nur auf den
nonbass abgehoben sondern wünschte sich
im Grunde genommen die Auflösung der
Ukraine als Staat Frau Eickendorf und
trotzdem noch mal die Frage auch ein
Präsident beiden sagt wir müssen
irgendwann an mit der möglichst
stärksten mit
strongers possible position at the
legociation table müssen wir an diesen
Verhandlungstisch mit der besten
Position sie sagen es kann mit dem
keinen Fall also mit Putin kein
Verhandlungsergebnis geben
offensichtlich geht der amerikanische
Präsident aber davon aus dass am Ende
verhandelt werden wird ja davon müssen
wir ausgehen weil wir können ja nicht da
darauf setzen oder damit kalkulieren das
Putin entmachtet wird aber wir wollten
ihnen ja erst noch so schwächen dass er
keinen solcher Angriffskriege überhaupt
noch mal führen kann und dann
Entschuldigung wollte sie nicht
unterbringen und habe es ja ich würde
noch mal gerne auf
das Wording Zeitenwende zurückkommen
warum nennt denn Olaf Scholz den 24
februar eine Zeitenwende weil das war
der Punkt wo wir nun wirklich erkannt
haben und auch Deutschland das nun dafür
immer stand den Ausgleich mit Russland
zu suchen wo wir nun wirklich erkannt
haben nach 20 Jahren
kompromissversuchen nach 20 Jahren
Devise Wandel durch Wandel nach 20
Jahren genau das zu versuchen den
Ausgleich mit Russland zu finden mit
diesem Regime dass das nicht
funktioniert hat das ist ein ganz klares
Bekenntnis eine ganz klare
Positionierung die Putin damit
vorgenommen hat er hat im Prinzip nicht
der Ukraine alleine den Krieg erklärt
sondern der westlichen Welt und deswegen
würde ich einfach dafür plädieren wir
müssen den Blick weiten es kann keine
sichere Welt geben mit einem starken
Wladimir Putin das ist meine These
und die Teil der Kiesewetter wir fragen
noch mal Frau Quadbeck nach der
politischen Situation in diesem Land 50
Prozent der Menschen sind voller Sorge
in Bezug auf diesen Krieg und finden
dass die Maßnahmen
nicht ausgeweitet werden sollen würden
sie
wie schauen Sie nach Berlin was würden
Sie denken wer auch in diese
ampelregierung wird sich durchsetzen
wir sind da auch eine sehr kritischen
Punkt wenn man auch mal darauf schaut
wie jetzt eigentlich das Sondervermögen
im Bundestag zustande gekommen ist da
kann man
eigentlich nur sagen puh zum Glück ist
die Kuh noch mal so gerade vom Eis
gezogen worden weil es ja nicht nur so
war dass die ampelparteien einen
Ausgleich mit der Union finden mussten
sondern es war ja auch untereinander
nicht ganz einfach sich da auf die
entsprechende Formulierung zu einigen
und was man jetzt eben schon als
Gewitter heraufziehen sieht ist die
Frage wie verteilen wir künftig die
natürlich knapper werdenden Mittel
Deutschland kommt aus einer Phase in der
wir jedes Problem mit unserem Geld lösen
konnten wenn es ein Problem gab dann gab
es so daran haben wir uns gewöhnt ein
großkoalitionären Kompromiss der sehr
teuer war und der dafür gesorgt hat dass
am Ende alle etwas bekommen haben
2022 soll zumindest nach dem Wunsch des
Finanzministers die FDP das letzte Jahr
werden in dem die Schuldenbremse nicht
eingehalten wird 2023 Stunden dann noch
zehn Milliarden Euro Neuverschuldung zur
Verfügung das wird nicht noch nicht
einmal ausreichen um ein weiteres
Entlastungspaket für die Leute zu
schnüren und es ist aber so dass weite
Teile der Bevölkerung und eben nicht nur
die unteren Einkommensgruppen sondern
natürlich auch die mittleren
Einkommensgruppen inzwischen sich
überlegen müssen ob sie tatsächlich
ihren Standard noch so halten können und
vielfach sich auch im Alltag schon
einschränken weil sie sehr schnell
merken dass das Girokonto schneller am
Ende des Monats leer ist als das bisher
der Fall war das heißt im Grunde
genommen schreit es nach der nächsten
Entlastung Scholz hat ja im Bundestag
darüber noch gar nicht gesprochen auch
eine konzertierte Aktion angekündigt
zwischen Arbeitgebern und Gewerkschaften
wo es darum geht eine lohn-preisspirale
zu verhindern also dass die Löhne
steigen und damit die Inflation erst
recht angeheizt wird nur wie soll das
Ausgehen der Lohn Verzicht wird nicht
dazu führen dass die Leute dann besser
mit ihrem Geld hinkommt und es macht im
übrigen die Unternehmen auch nicht
glücklich wenn die Kaufkraft sinkt das
heißt am Ende müsste noch einmal viel
mehr Geld reingepumpt werden was nicht
da ist und das wird auf eine harte
Auseinandersetzung hinauslaufen zwischen
SPD und grün einerseits und dem
Finanzminister andererseits und der
Druck aus der Bevölkerung es wird aber
groß sein dass da noch etwas geschieht
und da wären wir dann eben auch noch mal
bei dem Thema wie groß ist denn
eigentlich noch die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine weil dann wird auch schnell
der ein oder andere Populist eben nach
Osteuropa gucken und sagen na gut die
Sorgen ja auch dafür dass die
Kriegsfolgen sie nicht ganz so hart
treffen und mehr auf die eigenen Ego ist
also auf die eigenen egoistischen
nationalen Interessen schauen Kevin
Kühnert hat gerade noch gesagt Olaf
Scholz plädiert nicht dafür dass sich
die Arbeitnehmerseite nicht auch auf
Lohnerhöhungen verständigt mit den
Arbeitgebern nicht wollen dass wir jeden
Monat mit Milliardenbeträgen nach dem
Gießkannenprinzip Leuten aufkleben hier
300 Euro da 400 Euro dann müssen
Beschäftigte in die Lage versetzt werden
aus ihrem Erwerbseinkommen heraus auch
mit Preissteigerungen leben zu können
aber ich will Frau Quadrik schon darauf
hinweisen dass das worauf sie zurecht
gerade hingewiesen haben ein bisschen
nach meinem Dafürhalten dem widerspricht
was sie eingangs gesagt haben nämlich
das Deutschland hinten dran wäre bei der
Unterstützung wenn ich natürlich nur zu
einem Zeitpunkt vor zwei Monaten
irgendwelchen Waffenlieferungen
zusammenrechnen und daraus eine
Bilanzierung mache dann kann man zu dem
Schluss kommen aber meine These würde
folgendermaßen gehen eine effektive
Unterstützung für die Ukraine wird auf
mittlere und lange Sicht wenn wir
wirklich einen langen Atem brauchen
darin bestehen eine Politik zu machen
die eine stabile Mehrheit der Menschen
in diesem Land hier in Deutschland auch
ökonomisch in die Lage versetzt zu sagen
wir stehen das durch weil wir den
Eindruck haben dass es eine gerechte
Lastenverteilung hier gibt die Leute
haben verschiedene Bauchgefühle zu
dieser oder jener Waffenlieferung das
kann man sich im Fernsehen erklären
lassen von Experten man kann sich
Außenpolitik von Experten erklären
lassen aber in der Supermarktkasse ist
jeder sein eigener Experte das verstehen
die Leute sehr wohl im Moment und
deswegen hat der Kanzler auch gestern
seine Rede mit diesen Auswirkungen
angefangen und das in den Mittelpunkt
gestellt weil er sehr wohl versteht dass
auf das diesem Level darüber entschieden
wird ob wir im Herbst Raum und Zeit
haben auch über Odessa zu sprechen oder
ob wir in erster Linie über den Öltank
und über die Nebenkostenabrechnung reden
nur diese stabile diese stabile Lage
diese stabile Politik auf lange Strecke
werden sie natürlich nicht mit neun
euro-ticket und Tankrabatt als
Knallbonbon ja hinbekommen sondern da
hätte man auch jetzt schon andere Mittel
eintüten müssen um eben der Bevölkerung
auch zu zeigen hier wir machen eine
Politik die auf Dauer angelegt ist also
die Signale von diesem Sommer sind genau
das Gegenteil von dem was sie gerade von
der Einfordern von sich selbst ja bei
Lohnpolitik macht in Deutschland nicht
die Bundesregierung deswegen ist der
Appell dass wir jetzt Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitnehmer zusammenholen und mit
darüber zu sprechen was erwartet uns
eigentlich ist genau ist genau richtig
und wir haben ja immer gesagt die ent
ganz Pakete die auf den Weg gebracht
wurden im Wert von über 30 Milliarden
Euro die sind deshalb so gestrickt wie
sie gestrickt wird weil es darum ging
schnell und effektiv eine Soforthilfe zu
signalisieren aber auf Dauer kann man
nicht mit immer neuen Soforthilfen
arbeiten und auf Dauer muss man eben
auch klar sagen Leute mit solchen
Einkommen wie ich unterstelle es jetzt
einfach mal wie hier am Tisch versammelt
sind werden damit leben müssen dass der
Puffer am Ende des Monats ein bisschen
kleiner wird während Leute die schon in
der Vergangenheit kein Puffer am Ende
des Monats hatten von diesem Puffer auch
nichts mehr abgeben können so muss
Entlastung dann in Zukunft aussehen dort
auch nach Einkommensgruppen stärker zu
unterscheiden